bio express de journaux se trouve sur
boîtes noires ceinture d'oracle coûte
seulement 3 euros sur steam et quelle
race est intéressant c'est parti lui un
home sweet home regarder j'adore qu'on
joue à des jeux jolie comme ça en fait
l'angle de vue il est très large ce qui
donne un effet assez assez flippant
trouver les clés de la cellule allumez
le générateur est rentré dans la maison
ok donc niveau histoire en fait on est
un chasseur de relique est un vieil ami
qui nous a appelés pour nous dire que
dans cette maison il ya un miroir
légendaire et du coup en tant qu
excellent chasseur de reliques
on veut trouver le miroir bien sûr de
qui nous redit qu'il faut allumer le
générateur qui est dans le cellier et on
trouvera les clips du générateur
derrière la maison entre l'antenne
martin voilà donc partant c'est notre
fameux potes qui nous a appelés pour
nous dire hier mais au regard
légendaires là bas alors là jusqu'aux
c'est la fontaine pcf
ok bah voilà un petit trousseau de clés
et maintenant il faut trouver là le
scellier qui en toute logique devrait se
bat voilà on a fait le tour et on peut
descendre pour aller crever j'ai un gros
générateur à il avait la flemme de
modéliser j'étais à l'inter ils agissent
mais tu vois des coupes le but rémois là
la porte de la maison est maintenant
ouverte on peut rentrer alors on a
encore une note book et malheureusement
je dois partir à cause des gens qui
travaillent tu peux t'asseoir deuxième
étage cherchent une porte verrouillée tu
trouveras les clés qui correspondent
dans une chambre au niveau de l'ailé
gauche
ok ou la porte fermée s'il vous plaît
c'est celle là vous avez besoin d'une
clé connard quoi c'était une belle
boutade qui s'usent et que ces endroits
bizarres
assez pour monter s'arrêter plafond qui
font huit mètres c'est scandaleux ou
bien les ailes gauches à doit être par
là la vajol le miroir et dans le cellier
mais le problème avec la porte ne
s'ouvre pas l'un de ces jurys doivent
ramener un outil spécial pour pouvoir
péter la porte
c'est parfait j'espère qu'ils ont fait
comme ça en prend le miroir on se pète
et
et au lac et al horria un petit feu qui
a été fait pour moi sommeil ça c'est
moins mignon allez on s'endort sans le
rire démoniaque et tout se passe bien on
se réveille
le feu est éteint j'ouvre alors une
porte
complètement t du q7 porte
olala pas parfait c'est bon et un toit
c'est ces miroirs ça c'est le miroir qui
nous parle je suis sûr il nous dit en
latin démoniaque rien attends je me suis
carrément mis mieux dans ce lit deux
places
qu'est ce que c'est que ça pour aller en
bas il est nécessaire de trouver la
pièce secrète
adji kâ à jk ok bah écoute et montre ses
escaliers ayuso assez sales trucs secret
mais attends mais qu'on monte des
marchés une porte fermée ça à quel
moment elle qu'elle monte sans ses
galères et c'est génial
en plus il tue revendit les touche ok là
on est sûr j alors que ça change bordel
adacore s'offre à cette porte là en fait
d'ailleurs faut trouver la porte que ça
ouvre dix minutes au milieu ce but
[ __ ] mais si quoi que ça ouvre la fin
j'ai besoin de faire toute la maison
c'est aucune porte pas possible je me
suis moqué de cette énigme de ce1 en
fait c'est une énigme de deux mecs en
master et en france il ya une pièce
secrète ok ça s'active un mécanisme et
vous trouvez où est le mécanisme auquel
va refaire un petit tour
j'en ai marre en cliquant sur absolument
tout ce qu'on trouve bordel j'ai pas un
coussin magique avec une trappe en
dessous ce jeu est un [ __ ] ciel c'est
évident que le miroir il est la balade
soudan puisse faire comme s'il y avait
cent mille éléments en quoi le vélo la
[ __ ] du vélo non le canapé vous ont
déçu non sous le tapis non [ __ ] de jeu
à trois euros 3 euros pour racheter ont
valu mais cette lumière la maison à
s'écrouler mais j'en sais rien moi ce
qui va se passer en faisant quoi j'ai
suis en train de perdre en plus violent
de l'awb états unis les jeunes que pour
est là je vais vous dire ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est de quitter l'avion
s'est dirigé le board
eva 3 euros pour craquer son [ __ ] de
10 minutes au milieu aux 8 points à 3
étoiles avant le h puisque c'est un
manoir 13 3 étoiles tapis sur h pour j
tu appuies sur capot h et avait surgi
pour k et pg g passe et d'appuyer sur
p&g c'est peut-être ça le piège
découvert ce formidable dans trois deux
un bon quoi faire l'option très simple
qui consiste à voir la réponse dans une
[ __ ] de vidéos
ok première vidéo le mec trouve pas
hélas le titre de la vidéo
white mirror le jeu qui m'a ennuyé à
mort voilà parfait ya forcément une
vidéo sur le net ou le gars a trouvé
c'est pas possible donc et troisième
vidéo le mec trouve absolument pas
années lumière où l'état
je suis asthmatique chasse assez
exceptionnel à laval je vais vous dire
la réponse à l'énigme et vous allez
vraiment exposés dncs que c'était en
fait fallait faire j tout cas qu'à tout
h&h tout j mais j'ai fait j'ai fait un
code qui dit de 1h vraiment pendant une
heure j'ai cherché comme le plus grand
écho la solution à ce miracle
au final cette porte ramène ici c'est
parfait vraiment je suis hyper heureux
alors du coup à paroles à la
bibliothèque s'est ouverte c'est
vraiment fantastique est là on va aller
par là on va rencontrer à mons et va
nous tuer et je balançais l'outro à la
passion est décédé là est là devant jeu
vidéo non mais je voulais dire c'est
quoi le monstre aux grands pays soit à
fog mode auto etc à 11 bah écoutez on va
aller loin loin d'ici à peut-être que ça
s'est ouvert là pour le ba ba voila il
avait à voir le miroir et fin du jeu on
n'en parle plus alors je suis pas
nouveau j'habite à hasnon non non non au
caire dans un grenier d'un sous-sol
pardon dégueulasse parfait alors trouver
une porte d'un trouve trois tournevis et
retourne dans l'abri ok moi bâtard le
mec il a modifié sa voix sur ce site
j'ai la haine contre ce jeu je vous
promets elle a passé une heure à
résoudre une énigme de merde
oh ça va mal mais le pire c'est que
personne n'arrive à ben voilà une boîte
à outils deuxième casse à outils
troisième caisse à outils on est bon bah
voilà on en parle plus ouah on est dans
une cave avait géré j'apprécie
graphiquement quand même j'avoue prouver
la sortie voilà c'est assez clair c'est
réécrit rouge sur blanc a encore une
énigme
non c'est une blague versez une blague
c'est une blague c'est une blague oh oui
à chtouka cas tout est fait
elle mange pas ça marche pas non non non
mais là c'est un sketch là mais non mais
j'utilise la même mécanique que tu à
l'heure avec le code le nouveau code ça
marche pas et ben voilà les gens c'est
déjà la fin de cette petite vidéo
j'espère qu'elle qu'elle vous a attisé
n'hésitez pas à mettre un slip sur votre
tête et on se retrouve très bientôt
l'ips allez au revoir tout le monde
portez vous bien la cravate pis c'est le
rôle